economía en france 24 está conmigo en el
estudio daniel hablando con daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando de las
farmacéuticas que criticaron el apoyo
que el presidente de eeuu joe biden
le ha dado a esa idea de liberar las
patentes para agilizar la vacunación a
nivel mundial hola santiago buenas
noches mire el grupo de investigadores y
manufactureros farmacéuticos que es una
asociación que aglutina a los
principales fabricantes de vacunas
contra el hobbit 19 advirtió que esta
propuesta tiene dos efectos negativos
que va a debilitar las cadenas de
suministro y que proliferará las vacunas
falsificadas como lo explica una abogada
de patentes europeas
creo que sentaría un mal precedente es
gracias a la investigación científica
que ahora tenemos medicamentos
tratamientos y vacunas pero esto se debe
a las patentes en las que las empresas
siguen invirtiendo dinero y no tendrías
este tipo de inversión si no hubiera una
recompensa adecuada para las empresas
mire los datos que le traje santiago en
los dos días que han pasado desde que el
presidente joe biden se mostró de
acuerdo con eliminar los derechos de
propiedad intelectual las farmacéuticas
se han desplomado en bolsa moderna y
variante que bajaron más del 5% y la
calidad de facer fue un poco más
moderada el camino que viene ahora no es
fácil
los 164 miembros de la organización
mundial del comercio deben estar de
acuerdo en los últimos 7 meses ha habido
10 reuniones sin grandes avances pero
los países emergentes se enfrentan a
grandes economías como suiza y unos
miembros de la unión europea que
concentran a las grandes farmacéuticas
es una posición poco popular en esta
emergencia sanitaria mundial hablemos
ahora de perú que allí ya es posible
hacer un nuevo retiro anticipado de las
pensiones como ya ha sucedido en otros
países como chile sí señor esta
iniciativa hoy ha sido aprobada por el
congreso en marzo pero el gobierno la
objetó en abril porque la califica de
inconstitucional y amenazó con tramitar
una demanda de inconstitucionalidad
precisamente el mismo legislativo acude
ahora a una herramienta que ya ha usado
últimamente y que se llama aprobación
por insistencia que le permite saltarse
digamos la aprobación presidencial la
mayoría de los más de 7.5 millones de
afiliados a las administradoras de
fondos de pensiones van a poder retirar
lo equivalente a 4 mil 575 dólares de
sus aportes con algunas excepciones como
por ejemplo los mayores de 40 años que
no podrán dejar sus cuentas vacías
daniela con todo el revuelo de la
reforma fiscal en colombia' cuáles son
los países de américa latina que más
impuestos pagan santiago hay un informe
conjunto de la cepal la ocde y otros
organismos multilaterales
que mostró que en américa latina y el
caribe los impuestos que se recaudan
aportan casi un 23% de la economía pero
también lo discriminó por países miren
en cuba' los impuestos cubren el 42 por
ciento del pib mucho más que la
proporción en el llamado club de países
ricos les sigue en barbados brasil y
belice por el contrario los países cuyas
economías reciben menos impuestos son
guatemala república dominicana paraguay
panamá y méxico venezuela es el único
que no está incluido por falta de datos
también hay que hacer esa claridad
hablemos ahora de esa tensa relación
entre camberra y beijing suspendieron
sus diálogos económicos australia y
china cada vez más distanciados si
santiago mire tras meses de roces
diplomáticos
beijing decidió interrumpir este diálogo
que buscaba mejorar la relación es un
diálogo económico que sostenían desde
2017 argumentó que australia tiene una
mentalidad de guerra fría comillas y de
discriminación ideológica los lazos
bilaterales se tensaron en 2018 cuando
australia se convirtió en el primer país
en prohibir públicamente a liga
huawei de su red 5g y empeoraron cuando
este mismo país pidió investigar el
posible origen chino del corona bills o
la pelea ya está en el plano comercial
desde hace rato china ha impuesto
altísimos aranceles al vino australiano
y cambiará le ha respondido aplaudiendo
las sanciones de la unión europea contra
beijing por la supuesta violación de
derechos humanos en la región de
xinjiang indicadores como las fuerzas
principales bolsas la jornada de hoy o
street del cerro en positivo su
principal índice de dow jones hoy renovó
su récord histórico por los buenos datos
laborales publicados hoy en europa la
bolsa de madrid alcanzó su nivel más
alto desde febrero de 2020 y en américa
latina hubo cierres positivos impulsados
también en parte por el buen humor que
hubo en wall street la cifra el día para
el cierre 4.400 millones de dólares
santiago éstas han sido las ganancias
del gigante japonés nintendo durante la
pandemia o sea entre marzo de 2020 y
marzo de 2021 tuvieron un crecimiento
del 86 por ciento gracias a las
cuarentenas que obligaron a la gente a
quedarse en casa
jugando no muchas gracias daniela es
todo por el momento la economía siga con
nosotros buenas noches
siga todas